thank you
[Music]
welcome back to another great episode of
careful boys we have with us Mr Jake
Tran wow
[Applause]
I was just watching one of your videos I
was telling you earlier this guy makes
really great in-depth videos about
everything government
scandals like all kinds of really deep
stuff uh you have a Julian Assange video
you guys one of my favorites you got
things that most people don't even dare
mention hopefully you're calling out
Assange right for his crimes
[Laughter]
how did you get into doing videos like
that so it was always my dream to be a
YouTuber I should watched you guys in
like middle school and early High School
yeah like all the old Asian humor videos
how did you turn out so smart
watching our videos I know you're so
successful yeah yeah yeah what's the
secret yes I I I I had to do a bunch of
tries so my first try was a Taekwondo
Channel because I did that in high
school didn't work out so I gave up went
the traditional route became a web
developer got bored really fast once I
got the job I wanted so I went back to
YouTube and it took me like another year
of struggling until I kind of hit on
this style yeah and
I didn't go like the route of like these
super controversial videos right away
but at one point once I just start a new
channel or you post all of it like like
if you go far back enough on your
channel you see you're doing kicks and
stuff no uh different Channel I'll
completely okay those other videos are
kind of cringe
aren't the First videos always yes that
is true ours work
classic bro our first ones best hits
Greatest Hits
dude our videos we posted today are
cringe
because we shot those eight years ago
yeah where was I so oh yeah so at one
point I landed on this like video style
of like b-roll voiceover and then I
ended up watching a documentary on war
profiteering and it just like blew my
mind that people didn't know about this
but in my in my mind if I made a video
about this like no one would be
interested because who would be
interested in a video about war
profiteering except for like nerds like
me so I just kind of made it just to
like satisfy my own thirst yeah and it
ended up doing really well so I kind of
just kept going down this route of other
stuff related to this like more
crime business power wow when I first
saw your videos because I'm a fan of
your work and I and I didn't know that
you watched JK or nothing like that and
I've been following you for a couple
years I met I ran into one of your
videos during um lockdown actually and
it was like a series of how you
dissected like criminal organizations
yeah and I love documentaries about
Yakuza like Mafia and I've watched a ton
of them but then it's like you have a
fresh new perspective every single time
so that it's like telling the same story
but like with a different twist or you
have a different angle or a different
thing that I didn't know about so I'm
like I really like that even even all
these recent ones like about Julian
Assange or whatever right like there's
already so many documentaries out there
but then the way he just compiles it I
just don't know what that recipe is yeah
yeah so there's a secret but yeah a big
influence of mine was an author called
Robert Greene who wrote the book 48 Laws
of Power and Art of Seduction
33 strategies of war and a lot of human
nature yeah he's good so one of my
favorite authors and once I read 48 Laws
of Power that really blew my mind
because he framed it as you know
everyone around us is after power but in
today's society we have to be like very
cordial and uh appear to be fair and
stuff like that but underneath the
surface we still have all those same uh
dark human emotions of like greed lust
power that we did like centuries ago or
even like biological drivers too yeah
but today we we have to like appear more
fair so I kind of I really like that
angle of like his like how-to God on how
to be more powerful so I kind of took
that and applied that to the videos I
make so it's like how to how to become a
mafia member or something like that
versus just like you know calling them
bad do you have a favorite video
favorite video
um
the Nestle one is the highest viewed one
right now so that's part of the reason
why I like it so much but you're talking
about the Dark Side of nestle in that
one right yeah yeah can you help me
they're just so good at like I guess
putting yourself in that position can
you help me love Jeffrey Epstein yeah
what's your technology yeah what are the
48 Laws of Power that he's becoming you
know he's just like exercising his
biological needs or whatever do you
think he was CIA connected oh man I'm
definitely gonna get canceled for this
I'll just [ __ ] around yeah yeah
hypothetically historically yeah uh
sleeping with underage girls has been
like the norm throughout history so he's
uh so the laws of today are just recent
yeah he's just leaning into his nature
he's a traditionalist and sleeping with
underage boys have been abnormed for for
Elites for a long time it doesn't make
it okay because every time we say [ __ ]
like this people go so you're [ __ ] a
pedophile supporter he's like no you
[ __ ] [ __ ] we're just stating the
facts of what these rich and famous
people have been doing for long long
long long [ __ ] time [ __ ] [ __ ] I
can't say that out loud I have to say
the subtext of that
Jesus I know right like you got to spell
it out yeah every [ __ ] time so would
you say like
he's just a service provider to people
that are doing things or are after
things that have been going on for a
long time
he's like you can say that you can say
that like a young booty broker yeah this
probably is young booty broker that was
on his business card yeah I hope you
narrow some of your videos how to become
a young booty broker
clip art is [ __ ] Jeffrey Epstein
because you have to dodge the algorithm
in the [ __ ] box and [ __ ] like that'll
that'll pull it down yeah
um yeah there is a lot of like
contextual evidence that he was probably
a part of Massad uh the Jewish version
of the the Israel version of the CIA
yeah because Elaine's dad is was he KGB
Massad n uh he was Mossad I believe oh
but also the British one no I'm not sure
I think he was like a double triple
agent and my father he was a low agent
and James Bond one yeah the James Bond
one
008 and he had a big publication company
in the UK
it was it was the there was a [ __ ]
name I forgot the name of this but it's
like being this is how our documentaries
are
honestly I should do it I forgot this
[ __ ] David Cuts all this stock
footage yeah I love that it's still like
a prepared recorded voiceover though the
guy saying I forgot what it was
like so this is MI5 oh wait oh [ __ ]
that's MI6 okay yes
it's not even Drunk History it's just
Joe's [ __ ] history she Joe's memory
history freestyle history yeah what
about so Assange you said this is your
favorite that's your part your favorite
topic or the Nestle one uh my favorite
video just because of
how I like the storyline I created in
this video like uh keeping the tension
and stuff like that like the
storytelling I really like that what do
you think about what they're doing to
him right now like he's getting
extradited do you think he's dead dead
yet or well you think he's dead meat
like because because of that once they
extradite him successfully yeah if he
gets to America he's probably a chance
huh yeah either like life in prison or
suicide or suicide or suicide for sure
from all the research that you've done
is there like uh I guess a way that you
view the world or Society like man like
this world that everyone thinks operates
this way it's actually not like that at
all and how do you view it yes so the
reason why I can't make the videos I do
is I kind of look through everything
through the lens of power
like uh I look at the power incentives
and that's how I kind of come to the
conclusions I come to
um that's why I'm able to make the
videos I I'm able to make and
I guess one thing is
usually like
the Silicon Valley example if you've
seen that video in Silicon Valley like
from the outside to the public it's all
about you know Innovation creating all
these uh Innovative hyper growth
companies but on the inside it's kind of
like a Ponzi scheme word
DC's will uh kind of Mark up their own
deals
and they'll CR Founders and VCS will
create this narrative and push this
narrative up like this Super Hyper
growth Innovative company when in
reality it's like a company with a
website an app
like they haven't really invented
anything new let's look at nft
but
Yeah the more they frame it as like this
hyper Growth Company uh they can like
Mark up the deal and then hopefully go
public and exit so yeah that's why uh I
don't know Newman the guy behind wework
he just got uh like 350 million dollars
in funding from the biggest BC firm one
of the biggest a16z he's still doing
wework no he's doing something else now
oh because Masa Oshi son got murdered
off of wework a lot of people do so he
just got 350 million dollars in funding
from one of the biggest Venture Capital
firms in Silicon Valley AC 16z for a new
startup called flow where they're
basically doing weed work but for
apartments like fancy hipster apartments
with or like Community oriented or
whatever
and uh everyone was surprised like he
got funding and it's like not fair
because uh about all the controversy but
you know VCS they look for people they
look for Founders who know how to play
the game who know how to paint this
Narrative of like a super Innovative
high growth company so he like
understands the game so of course you
would bet on it yeah so now his company
before with this funding round it's
valid at a billion dollars already I see
so they're just trying to dump on the
hype so the VCS they they bet on this
guy it blows up other billionaires goes
oh [ __ ] that's a that let's throw money
at that [ __ ] yeah and then they [ __ ]
rug pull the billionaires
or the public if they go public yeah
yeah oh that's interesting allegedly
have you allegedly taken a look at
presidential libraries and how they're
funded presidential libraries oh yeah
Presidential Library the ones that are
named after the president yeah no yeah
the ones that President's built and they
they have these foundations built around
them that are also tax shelters and they
basically get a they well their whole
administrations they give [ __ ] tons of
money in foreign aid and then it's sort
of interesting how foreign aid Finds Its
way back into their pocket when they're
building their presidential libraries
very interesting
no he was going to do the lighter side
of Subway Jared oh yeah we should do a
Subway
did Subway really lose all that weight
he humanizes all these guys you know
what I mean like you help me help me
sympathize with them so do you ever like
you know throughout making all these
videos with these kinds of topics you
never got afraid somebody would show up
at your door and be like in a suit like
you know that's one of the most common
questions I get but in reality all the
stuff I make is like public knowledge if
they're just digging for it you'll find
it it's not
it's not like an actual journalist like
I'm definitely not a journalist it's not
like I'm a journalist like the guy Jamal
khashoggi who got uh butchered by the
Saudi Arabian uh family
like he he was just like a normal
journalist in Saudi Arabia like he does
normal stuff that journalists over here
would do yeah but he broke the wrong
story basically oh yeah you can't do
that to Prince Ali Ben talal dude yeah
uh pencil man or whatever yeah but he's
very rich yeah so he was
yeah he he kept poking the bear he moved
to America I kept poking the bear with
the Washington Post so he had to go to
Turkey for like to the Embassy to get
like a Visa or something uh his wife was
waiting in the car
he never came out and then like a little
bit of time later
the news broke that he got like
literally cut up in the embassy
something like that jeez
well what's what's interesting to me is
that when people look at public record
Journal like journalism just normal
journalism and then call them a
conspiracy theorist like the stuff they
would say like a lot of your videos are
probably conspiracy videos but it's not
a conspiracy if it's been proven to be
true right yeah like people usually like
fans usually come up to me and say like
you know I really like conspiracy so I
love your videos but I never viewed
myself
Conspiracy YouTube channel when you look
at man on the street interviews and
people don't even know who the vice
president is you start to understand
when more people think that maybe war
profiteering is a conspiracy or like
okay that's true yeah because you've
never thought about it yeah they don't
they don't know they're trained by the
media who are owned I mean
operation Mockingbird like all these
media entities are really in the pockets
of the intelligence agencies that they
don't even [ __ ] criticize they don't
criticize them in fact they hire all
these guys they hire half of the time
you're watching msnbcc and CNN Fox News
you're talking to intelligence
that's the best part dude
get the more your hat just like goes off
like oh it looked like the it was like a
mood ring like Azure the more sincerely
drop the more it was like the more
enlightened you were getting enough you
guys liking this [ __ ] it's like a data
processor yeah you're very vibrant right
now
moves to the music it's about thrown out
of batteries oh man you better charge
that thing I know
it's like my hat is fighting to survive
and I'm like no it's just Vibes it's
feeding off your vibrator feeding off
The Vibes so now that you make a lot of
these kind of videos do you think um you
know sometimes you attract a lot of
like QA non-types and like people that
are just like [ __ ] out out of this
world oh I've got some like very strange
emails I'm like oh like those types like
really strange what would they say I
never read the full email oh really you
go off one sentence you're like oh [ __ ]
yeah no way too many commas in this
sentence I don't know like one was like
put me on like some mailing lists where
he would just send me like links to like
very strange articles so I had to like
block his email so stuff like that but I
want to say that's like the majority of
other viewers there's probably people
trying to cite your videos to support
their random weird problems and they're
like no this guy said it
okay when are you gonna come out with a
lizard people video yeah what's your
take on that
no comment no comment I actually I
actually did a deep dive on Hollow Earth
recently and it's [ __ ] hilarious wait
what's Hollow Earth it's so dope it's
[ __ ] hilarious it's like there's a
sun inside of our Earth you know we
think it's like the Earth's core it's
actually like a sun and like inside
there there's like oceans yeah and like
a whole [ __ ] thing Inside Out World
like and you can only enter through like
Antarctica yeah through the polls
there's a hole there that's pretty
positive and it goes to the other side
of the Earth yeah it goes all the way
through and their argument is well how
do you know what's really inside the
middle of the Earth no one's been there
that's a strong argument how come no
one's recording it
all right
I don't know why you're saying this [ __ ]
I think it all started from a pilot that
went across the uh over the Antarctica
and he makes claims that he had to make
an emergency landing and this whole
thing and he wrote like a novel about it
um and there was a whole nother world
out there and it just went from that oh
so and I think that movie 300 lead or
not under the sea but the what you know
like when people go to there's an old
[ __ ] movie where they like go through
the core of the earth 30 000 leagues
below the sea
with Hillary Swank oh yeah that's right
[ __ ] classic 90s movie really is it
called the core yeah okay because I was
thinking like a 1950s movie but it
probably is that actually okay uh so you
know what I would dude if I was an alien
race and and I wanted to [ __ ] with
humans I would make it so that yeah we
take control of some guy's plane and
then polar bears are landing him so he
could never tell a [ __ ] story where
everyone's like you're a [ __ ] idiot
dude yeah and he's just going crazy his
Rocky chair I want anyone to believe me
yeah we were in polar bear outfits yeah
he's like polar bears land I mean no no
they could probably shape-shift into
anything oh yeah and so like yeah we'll
be polar bears we'll [ __ ] with this
idiot
I'm glad we don't have recreationally
cruel aliens like that not yet we don't
know if you is there a topic uh where or
a video that you posted where YouTube's
kind of [ __ ] with you a little bit
um anything related to like recent War
stuff like my Afghanistan video got
demonetized really wow yeah any clue
would they say did they say why
um it was about Afghanistan like the
follow-up in the title did it say
Afghanistan yes but can't the news talk
about Afghanistan why can't you talk
about I know I've checked and like new
station New Station YouTube channels
like they're still monetized for
Afghanistan related videos but uh and
you're just reflecting the stuff that
they're saying yeah and I
there was nothing too violent in the
video and I requested a review for the
monetization and it was disapproved so
it's still demonetized what was there
what we're saying in that video
um I believe it was a summary of like
how we got here with Afghanistan like
the history of it and how we got here
and
in general I actually think YouTube is
actually pretty good with monetization
and uh not being too biased yeah
compared to like Tick Tock or Instagram
like Instagram Will Shadow back you
without telling you yeah Tick Tock
literally just says they shallow ban
people in their terms of service
so they're like open about it at least
but YouTube they actually like try like
they have the uh monetization it's a
little more favorable uh future
they uh the creators have a YouTube
manager that they can contact with and
uh we're not big enough because we never
had a manager I had one dude they're a
joke anyway they just read off of a
[ __ ] script too yeah um I don't know
my guy was pretty decent like uh a video
got to monetize I told him about it he
sent it uh up the chain of command and
it got approved maybe it's changed
they're good at that I think they're
good at that but if it's if it's
anything that kind of in the middle they
they read off of a script and they don't
know what to tell you and you're kind of
cycled around so yeah for me anyway but
yeah YouTube at least tries yeah that's
true because the other ones that are
like you're [ __ ] did you ever make a
video and then you were like
um you know for a while I didn't
uh I didn't want to make a Jeffrey
Epstein video but then there's no way
you say uh every Gypsy
partially a joke partially if you guys
uh just in case YouTube uh because the
Bots will read will like hear what
you're saying yeah
uh they were very strict about that with
covert related stuff yeah yeah they were
like if you just say coven it'll they'll
catch it that's true damn that's when we
were saying kovid remember yeah like uh
it happens to Linus Tech tips the chat
the tech Channel they said like Coven in
one video it wasn't even related to
covet and it caught it and got them
monetized wow so yeah that is an actual
thing but yeah I just said like
partially for that and partially because
I just think it's funny but yeah once I
came up with the idea for the YouTube
membership where they get you pay five
bucks a month and you get a private
documentary not released to the public
uh that's when I finally made the
Jeffrey Epstein video so that video you
can watch publicly you can only watch if
they're in the club yes but I did
release a public video
uh on how Jeffrey Epstein part one of
the ways he made his money was with an
actual Ponzi scheme oh the the first
Scandal right yeah yes and that promoted
the private documentary at the end and
that video um I was able to get away
with it because I didn't put Jeffrey
Epstein in a title just in his picture
in the thumbnail so yeah that was a and
I said average Epstein throughout the
entire house
do you have any thoughts on the Vegas
shooting which one and what happened
uh no thoughts I haven't really looked
into it oh okay yeah it's pretty
interesting what are your thoughts uh
well there's a police report that's like
live in the moment that says there's
multiple people in there it wasn't just
Steven Paddock it was like him and a
woman was there too in this in the room
in the official yeah in the official
police account but then in the news they
don't talk about that ever at all
there's it was the story is that Stephen
Paddock acted alone and all that stuff
but that again the police report it's
right there so it's just very weird
although there's a lot of very strange
stuff to it that I I followed that one a
little bit for a while in fact there was
a guy who was an investigative
journalist who was invested who was
looking into that one in particular and
he was just murdered by some politician
in in Las Vegas and uh but oh all that's
connected because I just heard about a
politician being thrown in jail right
now because he's tied to the murder of a
journalist yes and that journalist also
exposed him like personally and he just
recently lost a race like for public
office over in Nevada we got that coming
up wow yeah so so but he was also
investigating the Vegas stuff he was one
of the only journalists left he was like
the main dude he's the man got tired he
was a lead for that and there's a lot
still to investigate about that because
we still don't have answers in fact
there's no official account of what
happened that day except for what we
have from police reports but nobody
nobody like in the FBI who was looking
into it as mentioned really much at all
about it I heard the that they thought
it was that there's a woman in there
because when they were banging on the
door he said just a minute
that could be